oui
comme ok c'est du pain au chocolat qui
on a fait la nuit et puis
il y a mon chef qui commence à deux
heures du matin
il fait la nuit et puis moi je commence
à 3h on fait ensemble il met un pouce et
puis là ils sont nickel je m'appelle
mourir Mara et j'ai 20 ans c'est ici je
travaille
je vous présente mon chef Rémi et ça
fait 4 ans on travaille ensemble c'est
lui qui m'a pris
tout ce qu'il fait du pain décroissant
tout ça je suis venu en France et 16 ans
et j'ai commencé à sortir dans mon pays
parce que j'avais des problèmes de
famille et je suis venu au Mali au Mali
je suis parti en Algérie et Algérie je
suis parti en Libye et le souffrance qui
est Olivier aussi
traiter des gens comme des esclaves
c'était pas facile pour nous aussi on
s'est rencontré en 2018 il est venu lors
d'un stage parce que il voulait devenir
boulanger absolument suite ça s'est très
très bien passé donc on a gardé comme
apprenti pendant la crise du covid du
coup il a fait toute son apprentissage
uniquement en entreprise donc du coup ce
qui lui a valu de
d'échouer à son cap de la partie écrite
on l'a gardé comme boulanger salarié
parce que on avait besoin de lui déjà et
puis qu'il était formé parfaitement et
qui faisait parfaitement le travail si
demain il travaille plus là déjà moi je
pensais à lui qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui va devenir qu'est-ce qui va se
passer parce que c'est déjà un jeune qui
a eu qui a tellement vécu de choses
horribles qui est passé par des choses
que aucun être humain devrait vivre ce
qui va se passer c'est que on va devoir
réduire un peu la voilure au niveau de
notre de nos fabrication de notre
développement donc économiquement ça va
avoir un impact immédiat parce que de
toute façon on trouvera pas de boulanger
tout de suite ou alors vraiment il faut
un coup de chance on a déjà pas besoin
de ça parce qu'entre les problèmes
énergétiques les problèmes de matière
première les problèmes de justement
sociaux qu'on rencontre on a du mal à
trouver du personnel
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment fier de moi
parce que
quand je vais commencer
mon apprentissage je travaille pas tout
seul mais je dis je t'envoie tout seul
parce que je connais bien maintenant mon
boulot tout ce que je fais le pain les
cookies et la brioche tout ce que je
fais comme le pont qui sont tous là
tout cela
j'ai fait pas
je vais faire les clients et les clients
qui viennent sont super contents et puis
on a des belles baguettes et sont tous
contents on a reçu en novembre de ville
21 donc ça ça première ampfs et on a
immédiatement pris l'avocat sur Lyon
pour lui permettre de se défendre au
mieux on a saisi donc le tribunal
administratif de Lyon qui nous a rendu
réponse ensuite que c'était donc négatif
suite à quoi on a continué de ce de se
battre on a fait appel on a voilà on a
joué indirectement la préfecture on a
fait appel à des soutiens extérieurs
malheureusement rien n'y a fait et donc
il y a 15 jours on a donc reçu ce fameux
courrier de la préfecture nous demandons
de mettre un terme à son contrat et de
nous laisser 15 jours pour avoir un une
notre avis un droit de réponse ça fait
bientôt 3 ans 3 ans et demi qui
travaille tout seul l'après-midi qui
gère le magasin les cuissons le la
production des croissants la mise en
place pour le lendemain pour que je
s'ouvrir moi le magasin c'est le moment
c'est difficile pour moi parce que le
métier que tu fais ça fait quatre ans tu
te lèves dans la nuit à 4h et 2h du
matin de venir bosser et on te dit plein
de journées de laisser ses métiers je
peux dire c'est difficile je cotise la
mutuelle j'ai une maison Juppé à chaque
mois je paye mon électricité ça fait 3
ans et ici on me dit de laisser au
boulot comment je peux électricité
comment je peux mon courant comment je
peux ma maison comment je me nourris ça
va être difficile pour moi les
producteurs les artisans les patrons ont
besoin de ces jeunes les faire partir
dans leur pays ne va pas régler du tout
les problèmes puisque effectivement ils
vont devoir partir mais bien d'autres
vont arriver parce qu'il y a des
tremblements de terre parce qu'il y a de
plus en plus de misère dans les pays
lointains et que ces jeunes vont venir
vont revenir ou d'autres vont arriver et
qu'il va falloir les accomp on ne peut
plus du tout les ignorer va falloir les
accompagner
l'embaucher définitivement qui puisse
s'établir en France avoir des papiers
avoir passé le permis voilà enfin faire
une vie de gamins de 20 ans normalement
en fait
monsieur Marat est un salarié dans la
même entreprise depuis 3 ans en contrat
d'apprentissage puis en CDI et
justifiant ainsi d'une expérience
professionnelle et de perspective
d'intégration peut demander un examen de
sa situation administrative en postulant
à l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour
en qualité de salariés démarche qu'il
doit cependant réaliser lui-même ainsi
qu'indiquer en août 2021 le recours à
des tiers de mandataires étant proscrit
pour les demandes de titres de séjour
[Musique]